première audience du procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 s'est
ouverte à 12h30 et la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris où un important
dispositif de sécurité est mis en place
des centaines de crs et de gendarmes
mobiles vont se relayer jour et nuit
pour assurer la tenue de cette séquence
judiciaire historique selon le ministre
de l'intérieur le risque terroriste sera
démultipliée lors de ce procès fleuve
pour lequel trois mille personnes seront
attendues certains jours 145 j'en ai
deux plaidoiries
1765 parties civiles 330 avocat 20
accusés des chiffres impressionnants
pour un procès inédit auquel assistent
katia pique nique ce procès des
attentats du 13 novembre est hors norme
historique il a débuté vers 13h
aujourd'hui des centaines de personnes
ont afflué au palais de justice dans
cette immense salle d'audience
construites au sein de la salle des pas
perdus où je me trouve actuellement ce
procès s'ouvre sur l'appel des 1765
parties civiles donc les avocats sont
appelés à la barre pour égrainer cette
liste des victimes qui pour certaines
n'ont pas voulu se présentent au pad
justice parce que c'est trop douloureux
mais évidemment d'autres souhaitent
assister venir chercher des réponses
veulent que justice soit faite propose
d'écouter thierry rescapés du bataclan
qui vient ici aujourd'hui en mémoire des
victimes on va écouter et il y en a
certainement un ou deux qui va parler et
parler quoi l'organisation leusiens
voilà moi j'ai donné les armes tout ça
mais il ya il n'y a pas de pardon il n'y
a pas de de faire des choses comme ça on
fait par ont tué des jeunes
pour rien quand je vais témoigner je
vais témoigner le 18
le 18 octobre bah je vais je les regarde
et je les regarde et non pas pour pour
moi j'ai pas peur de les regarder mais
pourquoi ses 90 ans ces pauvres gens
parce que me quand je suis sorti de ce
récit jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin j'ai
attendu que la berri nous dit libre
vraiment pour pour sortir donc je resté
plus de trois heures enfermé et j'ai vu
des choses horribles j'ai dû enjamber
des corps sans que ces essais c'est
marquant les avocats ont bien sûr
préparé les parties civiles au
déroulement de ce très long procès de
neuf mois on écoute géraldine berger
stenger avocate des parties civiles
depuis six ans on leur explique un petit
peu comment va se tenir le procès mais
c'est vrai que c'est un procès un peu
hors normes donc il va falloir surtout
la difficulté c'est de tenir les 9 mois
parce que c'est très long donc très
éprouvant parce qu'un procès c'est très
éprouvant pour les parties civiles donc
c'est surtout voilà cette difficulté et
puis on a un planning mais le planning
va évoluer au fur et à mesure donc là
aussi je leur ai dit attendez il faut il
faut faire attention parce que certains
ont déjà prévu de venir tel et tel jour
mais je leur ai dit bon bah voilà il
faut être assez
à l'écouté de ce qui va se passer parce
que les choses peuvent évoluer parlons
des accusés ils sont au nombre de 20 et
14 seulement vont comparaître puisque
s'ils sont présumés morts alors parmi
ces 14 11 sont en détention et trois
comparaissent libres quand il fait bien
- financés par exemple les attentes a
fourni des armes font des faux papiers
il ya des traces de dents des plans
qu'ils ont été chauffeur ils ont aidé le
commando il ya des traces très clair il
ya des preuves de préparatifs
d'implication très forte dans ces
attentats alors salade et slam le membre
le seul membre du commando qui soit
toujours vivant aujourd'hui s'est
exprimé de manière agressive à la barre
il a commencé par dire je tiens à
témoigner qu'il n'y a pas de divinité à
part à l'ail que mohammed est son
prophète
ensuite il a refusé de donner le nom de
sa mère et de son père et quand on lui a
demandé de décliner sa profession il a
dit qu'il avait délaissé toute
profession pour devenir un combattant de
l'état islamique donc voilà comment ce
procès a commencé aujourd'hui sur une
note glaçante